isn't that interesting Tucker Carlson
he's defending a Muslim now right right
right it's subhanallah actually discuss
all of the evidence
um that is very favorable that shows
that they they didn't commit any crimes
in this case
pretty obviously a setup Tina I mean
let's stop lying these guys were super
unpopular with the people in charge and
now they're in a remaining in jail under
quote Romanian law like obviously no
I think you you said it yourself Tucker
yeah I did because like let's stop
pretending let's stop playing that's
exactly what this is I just appreciate
the update sure I was gonna say it's
frustrating to be on the um defense
right now unable to respond to all of
the one-sided leaks that have come out
when we have exculpatory evidence but
we're not able at this point to discuss
it yet and to put it out for the world
to see you know strange times
Tucker listen we we may have had our
disagreement I don't remember if I've
been on a show I don't think so but but
I've been on other Fox News shows and
really I want to thank Tucker for
speaking out because very principle that
is a principled position and it makes
perfect sense and it's important I think
more in the media speak out you know
Romania has to be taught a lesson this
isn't this isn't acceptable have you
seen some of these arguments or
somebody's attack coming from Muslims
who will say oh you're defending someone
who's X Y and Z who was involved in this
that oh absolutely and listen these are
things from his past sure sure I mean
it's there's so much toxicity in in
regards to having these kinds of
conversations and and people want to
take some of the and to be frank Tate's
done some horrible things in his past
I'd be very Frank with that you know
what I'm saying I mean running some of
the businesses certainly are not Islamic
whether it's gambling whether it's in
involving females there's things that we
as Muslims absolutely reject but I also
believe as he's going on his path as
Islam he himself would absolutely reject
you know Islam purifies it destroys what
came before and what we want to do is we
want to be
barriers to God's mercy to humanity that
only those who are with us and like us
and agree with us should have God's
mercy and we forget God's mercy
encompasses all things and on that point
out I do want to share one of my
favorite Hadith because it's a lesson
for all of us look whatever Tate did in
his past
doesn't come anywhere close to what
Washi Allah who did we all know what she
did Washi was an assassin he was hired
to assassinate the uncle of the Prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam and
he did so and then he desecrated his
body and we know how close Hamza was to
the prophet sallam so why she eventually
he realized the truth he wanted to
become Muslim
and so he went to the prophet saw I said
he said listen the Quran says believers
do not commit shirk don't worship other
than Allah I've worshiped Idols the
Quran says Believers don't fornicate I
fornicated the Quran says Believers
don't kill the innocent and I've killed
the innocent I killed your uncle what
hope is there for me to become Muslim by
and far washi's done worse than what any
of us including Tate could ever do you
know from the murder to the to the
fornication you name it he did it he did
it all he did it all and yet he went to
the prophet saying I want to repent now
the prophet saws said listen you killed
my uncle get out of here there's no
mercy for you that's what we would have
done maybe if we love our uncle we don't
want to see his killer go to paradise
but the prophet I said was a mercy to
all creation he transcended even these
personal differences and the political
differences he waited till the
Revelation came and then Allah revealed
the verse yes believers do not kill do
not fornicate do not commit shirk and
whoever does that will get a terrible
punishment except for those who repent
and believe and do righteous Deeds not
only will Allah forgive them but he will
replace their evil with righteousness
how about the man who killed 99 and then
exactly you got this beautiful situation
beautiful story and you know what the
story she doesn't finish why she
actually didn't jump on at that moment
because he said these are too many
conditions okay I will believe I will
repent but how do I know my good deeds
will make up for it so then Allah
revealed a second verse of Mercy saying
Allah does not forgive shirk but he
forgives anything besides that to
whomever he wants and again why she
didn't jump on it he said too many
conditions how do I know Allah wants to
forgive me
and then the verse came tell my servants
who wronged themselves do not give up
hope in the mercy of Allah Allah
forgives all the sins altogether
so that is the mercy of Allah he can
forgive even the worst of people he can
forgive the person he went from being
cursed for killing the uncle the prophet
saw I said lemon being a fornicator and
being a murderer to being may Allah be
pleased with him because he became us a
hobby so why are we trying to stop
Allah's Mercy from each other when
somebody becomes Muslim even if we
disagree with their past we ought to
welcome them and frankly regardless of
their religion when their rights are
trampled upon we all have to stand
vocally against that because if it's
their rights today it could be our
rights tomorrow if one and then you had
that example of the man who killed 99
people then he went and he ended up that
story is just 99. he literally killed
murderer you cannot get worse than
murder you know in Islam we have Allah's
rights and human rights and some of the
scholars have written that in many
circumstance human rights are actually
more dangerous more critical than
Allah's rights because Allah if you
violate his rights if you don't worship
him if you ignore him he's not hurt in
the least yeah you know what I'm saying
but human beings
we are limited so if you oppress me if
you hurt me I'm caused harm so you can't
just worship Allah and hurt me you know
what I'm saying and yet this person did
the work he committed murder 99 people
went to a scholar said Can Allah forgive
me and the guy said he had to cancel
culture you know and if anybody deserved
cancel culture to be somebody who killed
99 people so you can't even blame him
but he said what you and I would say bro
you killed 99 people you know what hope
is there what what you and I may say
right if we didn't know better so you
know what he's like well if I killed 99
I'm going to hell anyway what's another
one so he killed him too killed a
hundred people
and then he truly genuinely regretted it
he went to the other he went to the
other person who was wise and he said to
him I've killed a hundred
is there any hope for me and the person
said what can stand between you and the
mercy of Our Lord
but you can't just say you're sorry you
have to take meaningful change you have
to travel go to this you committed all
the sins in this city go to this other
get away from these bad friends get away
from the Bad Company what we say and we
say we say in Arabic the friend pulls
you know the prophet saws said that
we're all in the religion of our friends
and our Companions and this is the
amazing thing by the way with Tate what
I noticed is when he became Muslim
he's hanging out with other Muslims he's
going to the meship he's starting to
talk with different Scholars being in
righteous step by step step by step you
know we put such false standards for
people that he started to take those
steps of change so anyway this guy was
told you have to go to the city of the
righteous so he starts
traveling to the city of the righteous
and on his journey what happens we know
he passes away
so now the Angels come one of mercy and
one of Wrath the mercy wants to pull him
to Paradise the Wrath wants to take him
to Allah's you know to curse and
Punishment and they're arguing right the
the the mercy the angel of Wrath and
punches listen he killed 99 100 people
now we got to take him the angels of
Mercy said no he repented we got to take
him so Allah sends an angel to judge
between them and the angel says measure
from the two cities if he's closer to
the bad City
take him back to take them towards
Allah's displeasure and if he's closer
to the good City take him to the city of
righteousness which city was he closer
to he just left he was close to the one
he just left which means he should go
towards Allah's punishment but look how
merciful Allah is he told the bad City
move farther he told the good City moved
closer Allah moved two cities to forgive
a sinner who killed a hundred people and
then he was close to the city of mercy
and he was forgiven look
Allah calls you to forgive you let's not
let's not put any barriers between us
and Allah's mercy and others and Allah's
Mercy let's love for others what we love
for ourselves let's wish good for
everyone and this is the sad thing
because I notice there's a hatred by
which we talk about others you know it's
just people there's a lot of hatred I
mean even if the person is as bad as you
say
wish for him good wish for him a sincere
repentance wish for him that he becomes
a source of good for Humanity is that
healing that's going to help that person
to go ahead and get to a level that
they're going to leave off all of these
evil that's it that's become the best uh
person that they can in humanity and
that's the track record of Islam it
literally takes drunks fornicators
polytheists and makes them amongst the
most righteous and Pious you look at
Islamic history some of the most
righteous men in most Islamic history
before Islam were Highway robbers
literally we're Highway robbers but they
witnessed how those they robbed were
behaving and their connection with their
religion they repented and that's uh you
have people who are really close to
Andrew Tate some call him his manager
manager who also accepted I believe
brother uh Julius mashallah he's uh
someone who also accepted Islam you
could see him really taking Islam
serious and you know praying in the
Masjid and he's talking about also how
uh Andrew Tate is also starting to
anything he comes into he really takes
serious and now him being you can see
because now it would have been much
harder for him to connect with the Quran
sure and now this is kind of you know
Allah and Allah's wisdom inshallah Allah
uses him for the Deen for the dawah that
he's sitting him down and having him
connect with the Quran and until he gets
out he's much stronger there's benefit
everything that happens to the Believers
is of benefit and we certainly have to
believe that and we do and I've seen it
in my own life Allah says don't think
it's bad for you there's always good we
just have to keep that connection with
Allah you know Yusuf Ali Islam was
falsely accused thrown in jail and how
was he described by his companions we
see you amongst the righteous the time
in jail gave him an opportunity
to manifest his righteousness to display
his righteousness and then he was
liberated and likewise when he was
liberated in a position of power
his brothers came to him didn't know it
was his brother but also described him
as of the righteous and that's how we
Believers have to be righteous whether
in good times or bad times the prophet
saws said the first people to enter
Paradise are those who are thankful to
in good times and bad times that's the
nature of this world so as we close out
tell me now what would you think is a
way forward to facilitate some kind of
because obviously in this Romanian
system there's seems like that Justice
is not happening is not going to happen
public pressure you talked about you had
some success where you put the media so
we're using the little means that we
have others can also and then also
political pressure so a few things I
mean first before I jump into that I
really want to emphasize a point for
everybody that's watching because
Marshall I think you have a great
audience many are Muslim many are not
and those that are watching that aren't
Muslim sometimes may think Islam isn't
for them because they've committed or
they commit all these sins that the
Quran advises against and I want people
to understand the Quran advises you
against these sins to protect to make
you the best version of yourself
important Point yes and you know what no
matter how many of these sins you commit
every time you repent to Allah Allah is
willing to forgive you and give you a
freshly what I want people to understand
Islam is not just for the righteous we
think that to be Muslim grow out your
beard go for umrah given charity it must
mean you're righteous and if you have
any sins and shortcomings then you're a
hypocrite for even doing those righteous
things that's a satanic way of thinking
the pure way of thinking is the reality
is Islam is for each and every one of us
it is for the Sinners the prophet
himself said my intercession is for the
people of major sins amongst my ummah
never let your sins and weakness keep
you away from Allah drive you to Allah
whatever sins shortcomings you have let
that be motivation the prophet said Good
Deeds erase the bad Deeds so Islam is
for all of us it is for the Sinners
don't think you're a hypocrite because
you do a b c sin and now you're thinking
of becoming Muslim or you're Muslim and
you're going to the mosque or you're
going for umrah listen you're not a
hypocrite you're a human struggling on
their journey to Allah and that's what
Allah asks of us so keep it up don't be
hopeless